قال الامين العام للاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل نور الدين الطبوبي ان سياسه ترهيب
والتضييق التي تمارسها السلطات على العمل
النقابي لن تثنيه عن لعب دوره الوطني واكد
الطبوب بمناسبه اليوم العالمي للعمال ان
المنظمه لا ترضخ لاي سياسات لا شعبيه
تتعارض مع مصلحه الوطن والشعب على حد
تعبيره
ان السياسه تضيق على الحريات النقابيه
واتباعنا استعداء الاتحاد والعمل النقابي
والزج بمنادي للاتحاد في السجون
وحياكه الملفات من قبل بعض الوزراء
المعادين للعمل للنقابي وشن الحملات
المسعوره
ونشر الاكاذيب وهل سنه النقابيين لن
ترهبنا ولن تجعلنا نتراجع عن الدفاع عن
استقلاليه منظمتنا وعلى الحريات ولن تنجح
في الضغط علينا للتخلي عن حقوق العمال
والطبقات الشعبيه الكادحه
معنا الان من تونس مراسله الجزيره ميساء
الفطناسي حول فعاليات يوم العمال التي
نظمها اتحاد الشغل التفاصيل لديك ميساء
نعم ازدهار بالفعل هذه الفعاليه التي
نظمها الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل اليوم
بمناسبه العيد العالمي للعمال تضمنت رسائل
عديده في كلمه الامين العام لاتحاد الشغل
نور الدين الطبوبي هذه الرسائل التي توجه
بها الى السلطه التنفيذيه راسا وذلك في
اطار ما يعرف بتوتر العلاقه منذ اشهر بين
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل المنظمه
النقابيه وبين السلطه وبين رئيس الجمهوريه
تحديدا الرسائل اليوم تراوحت بين التنديد
والاستنكار وبين الترحيب في اخر استنكر
الامين العام للاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
ما وصفه باستهداف السلطه التنفيذيه للعمل
النقابي وبتشويه الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل وذلك من خلال الملاحقات القضائيه
التي يتعرض اليها عدد من القياديين
النقابيين اضافه الى اعتقال ايضا بعض
الاسماء النقابيه الاخرى وطالب الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل باطلاق سراح
النقابيين
المسجونين وخصوصا وان اعتقالي ما ياتي
بسبب نشاط نقابي لهما ايضا استنكر الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل ما وصفه بازمه
التعاطي تعاطي الحكومه مع مفاوضات صندوق
النقد الدولي للحصول على التمويل للخزينه
العامه للدوله وفي هذا الاطار استحسن ورحب
الاتحاد العامه التونسي للشغل من خلال
كلمه امينه العام اليوم بموقف الرئيس من
هذه المفاوضات ومن هذا الموضوع تحديدا
حينما اعتبر الاميره العام لاتحاد الشغل
نور الدين الطبوبي بان ما جاء على لسان
الرئيس قيس سعيد بانه يرفض ان تملي اي جهه
خارجيه سياساتها على تونس اعتبر بان ذلك
امرا مستحسنا وبانه يتماهى مع موقف
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل الذي يرفض
املاءات صندوق النقد الدولي على الحكومه
واستغرب اتحاد الشغل ما وصفه بالتناقض بين
موقف رئيس الجمهوريه في هذا الصدد وفي هذا
الملف وبين موقف الحكومه التي تسعى جاهدا
لتنفيذ شروط صندوق النقد الدولي للحصول
على تمويل للخزينه العامه في هذا الاطار
دعا الامين العام للاتحاد نور الدين
الطبوبي ادعى الى جميع الفئات السياسيه
وعلى راسهم الرئيس وايضا بقيه مكونات
المشهد السياسي في تونس دعاهم الى الجلوس
على طاوله حوار واعتبر اليوم بان الحوار
في تونس بات مساله حياتيه للخروج من
الازمات المتلاحقه التي تعيشها تونس على
المستوى الاجتماعي والاقتصادي خاصه وفي
هذا الاطار ايضا تحدث الطبوب عن المبادره
التي يستعد لاتحاد العامه التونسي
لتقديمها وهي مبادره الانقاذ الوطني التي
تحول اسمها اليوم الى مبادره تونس
المستقبل والتي قال الاتحاد بانه يصر على
ان هذه المبادره في خطوه اولى الى رئيس
الجمهوريه وذلك على الرغم من الانتقادات
التي جاءت على لسان الرئيس قيس سعيد لهذه
المبادره ولهذه الخطوه حينما اعتبر بان
الحوار الوطني اليوم وبان هذه الدعوات لا
فائده منها باعتبار ان مؤسسات الدوله
كالبرلمان وغيرها بدات فعلا بالاشتغال
وبان المؤسسات تم ارساؤها وبالتالي فانه
لا يمكن الدخول في حوار بالتوازي مع عمل
مؤسسات الدوله شكرا جزيلا لك من تونس
مراسله الجزيره ميساء